Well,
I have an Internet addiction,
a really,
really bad bad form of Internet
addiction where I,
you know,
I have spent a full eight hour days on
the Internet.
It's a point where I'm like,
I should just become like a one of those
employed bloggers or something because I
can't stop an average day.
I'll probably be on the Internet for
about four hours.
Um,
I have 12 to 15 blogs I might read
regularly and then I have to go through
all my new sites,
conventional news sites,
alternative news sites,
you know,
compare and contrast,
um,
know exactly what's going on in the
world several times a day.
Um,
so,
but,
you know,
for me,
the Internet on the upside of it,
sort of an endless source of
inspiration.
Um,
there's no excuse anymore.
I think for writers block really when
you could go hit up number of eccentric
blogs on topics from,
um,
you know,
you could read the blog of pro anorexic
women or you could read the blog of
soldiers in Iraq.
Um,
and in here,
those and in blogging offers this sort
of,
um,
I think very genuine first person a
universe that's,
that's endlessly fascinating to me.
I mean that,
that when you can find those blogs that
sort of feel like diaries,
so refreshing and,
uh,
there's always some kernel in those for
me to get very inspired by.
Um,
so I generally get way too many ideas
from the news and blogs.
Um,
and I,
and I sometimes encourage my students to
do the same.
Um,
all those hours that you're fiddling and
doing,
God knows what on the Internet,
um,
you can justify it and say you're
actually creating some form of art in a
sneaky.